she did yes he did yes that's next week
with the reserves oh so you know we won
him the starter
[Music]
how many envelopes you got four okay
okay
no no hold on Kenny you have to read the
first there's an order I'm giving Chuck
the first two no man no no no no no no
no oh my goodness Chuck there's a
there's a Autumn the captain the captain
read the cat okay ready yes oh my
goodness what did I do yes uh that
camera right there yes the captain
he's 96 years old he got to become the
all-time leading scorer soon
LeBron James wow LeBron James his 19th
All-Star Game 19 as a starter it is a
new record for the amount of All-Star
games played in a three-time All-Star
MVP it's his sixth time as a captain he
is 6-0 as a captain averaging just under
30 points eight and a half rebounds and
seven assists he passes Kobe with 19
All-Star selections and Kareem with 19
All-Star appearances LeBron James
what a career uh go ahead Kenneth yeah
unbelievable career the most astounding
part is longevity and not longevity in
terms of the the length of time that
he's playing at that level quality of
play you could say to you know the
debate about who's had a better 10 years
run or championships but no one has
played as great as he is playing at this
age this age no there's no no one in the
world has ever done that he's the freak
of freaks uh he is the uh he's the model
and this is what he doesn't get credit
for
he's the model citizen outside of
basketball if you want to figure out how
to handle yourself outside of basketball
you watch what he's done over 20 years
there's never been a negative thing
about his family his personal life other
than he made a decision on TV that
people didn't agree with that's it the
guy off the court is the model person
yeah I've said this two things I want to
say can we give a shout out to Kareem
Abdul-Jabbar sure like
to have this record
uh you know he didn't shoot threes
LeBron shoots threes
to be that I just think that when we we
don't appreciate how great he was I mean
I mean obviously LeBron is gonna break
the record at some point but this should
be a reflection on how great Kareem was
what he accomplished you know you talk
about championships in the NBA you talk
about all Championships in college and
things like that so shout out to the
great Kareem Abdul-Jabbar but I want to
piggyback on something to Kenneth said
I've said I think LeBron James is the
greatest basketball story ever maybe in
sports to be honest with you because
he's the only guy because as great as
Kobe Bryant was and Kevin Garnett uh
Tracy McGrady Dwight Howard those guys
they all kind of struggled in the
beginning yes that's he has 19 All-Star
games no no no he only missed one but
I'm saying he played good his rookie
year absolutely and to go bit to be the
guy from day one with all the pressure
expectations and to I've said this
publicly so to never get in trouble in
today's society where everybody's out to
get you at this level
it's the greatest sports story of all
time so congratulations to him when he
breaks the record model citizen I can
remember first watching him in high
school I arrived in Cleveland one of my
fraternity Brothers he got to watch his
kid play and of course I knew he was
going to be in the league but you know
he's
the way he has played his longevity uh
you know how how he's done it yeah liked
by everyone loved by everyone and he
will pass the record at some point and I
I myself have to say I I'm
professionally jealous
I would like to be at this point you
know I've always said
jealous of what I've always said about
the past Wilt chamberlaining points I
would have arrogantly said I'm the most
dominant big man ever so I would like to
be at this point right now to where I'm
the lead in school
but I pass you away
um
I got one okay I need one of you to read
pause and then the other one reads okay
so back to back can you go first the
first person
wow this is a prize ladies and gentlemen
not a surprise however Zion Williams wow
New Orleans Pelican so he got a wow I
did Chuck and then who do you have
Nicola jokic the two-time defendant NBA
champion The Joker all right let's do
the uh the surprise he's been an MVP
Champion
All-Star for Zion Williamson this will
be his first as a starter he's averaging
26.7 rebounds and a career-high 4.6
assists the Pelicans right now fourth in
the west he has missed 12 straight games
but when he has played Zion has looked
special Zion a starter for the west and
of course back-to-back MVP Nicola jokic
four-time All-Star this will be this is
his fifth time All-Star third straight
start averaging 25-11 and a career high
9.9 assists his 15 triple doubles leaves
the NBA and the Denver Nuggets at 34 and
15 are the number one seed in the
Western Conference but the story there
for me Zion Williamson named the starter
surprised only because of the injuries
you know um
the numbers that you read are All-Star
starter numbers
um however you know if he played in
these last 12 games I don't think you
you would have wild or we would have
right at him being named the starter
well I have a problem with it I said I
didn't that's the only problem it's too
many games that's it that's what yeah I
mean hitting the games as he missed 12
last 12 streams no no but he missed that
before then too how many guys does he
missed Mike I mean I I was in this
position a couple times when I missed
games and I was still named though the
All-Stars I'm not going to be able to
honor the guards yeah I'm gonna do the
guard yeah I started so congratulations
yeah congratulations on but all right
how many games has he missed yeah just
to answer the question
all right my favorite player in the
world Stephen Curry congratulations and
my second favorite player in the world
Luca doncic that is your Western
Conference backcourt step his ninth
All-Star his ninth as a starter he was
the MVP of last year's All-Star game
ever he had 50 points and 16
three-pointers this year averaging
29-6-6 18 30-point games the Warriors
right now 18 excuse me eighth in the
west but Curry now a nine-time All-Star
and Luca doncic his fourth All-Star he
is just 23 years old he is now a
three-time starter he leads the NBA with
a career-high 33.8 points per game he
leads the NBA in 20-point games 30-point
games 40-point games and 50-point games
bam he had that 60 21-10 game against
the Knicks and he is second in in triple
doubles Curry and Luca your two favorite
players you definitely can't be mad at
this pick uh two of the greatest players
in our game today Dynamic players a
great one-on-one players you know
All-Star game is a you know we we
celebrate the greatest players in league
but it's also a show people pay a lot of
money for us to put on the show so those
two guys in the back court shooting from
way behind the arch would definitely be
a great show and I have no